yeah shout out to dark man uh I love the
the new record obviously uh I feel like
you're the kind of artist that when you
get in with somebody that there might be
like five or six unreleased songs with
them sitting on a hard drive somewhere
yeah is that is that a fair assumption
in general with Ty yeah you know off and
on uh they're especially with me and bro
like we was on the uh
cover the double XL freshman together
and been doing this since then and now
he's one of the biggest artists out
there you know so shout out to Dirk and
all the hard work he's put in and it's
you know I'm happy for bro for sure to
see all that [ __ ] pay off how many songs
unreleased do you have with him I mean I
couldn't even say it but we got songs
for show
it's crazy because I kind of uh I even
just just back to the Chicago thing uh
obviously Dirk's
but oh gee like we've seen him
grow into this Superstar over the last
10 years first time I ever saw a guy
like little baby baby was on tour with
you yeah was it was that [ __ ] what
was that like 2014 and now he's
obviously a huge executive and he's
richer than everybody you know yeah wow
he did his thing you know what I'm
saying it's a it's good to see [ __ ] like
that but you're always pretty much hard
work pays off I was gonna say you were
pretty much tapped in with Chicago like
from the rip yeah yeah shout out to all
my brothers out there you know rest in
peace Fredo rest in peace Alfredo indeed